has come under continuous attack but the
ukrainians are finding new ways to
defend it
these men are pilots they operate drones
and they do it from the Shadows on the
city's outskirts it's pretty close to
the front line like one and a half
kilometer right and still it has places
to hide for us and there is a good
direct view of the sky above the
Battleground okay A good view of the
battlefield for this DIY team who do
things in an unconventional way
again took an online course to learn how
to fly while the drones were donated by
volunteers and his girlfriend pays the
subscription for their internet link
the Russians are more stuffy than us he
says
the main difference as far as I can see
that
we are more flexible and more of a
horizontal basis as especially if we
came from civilian lives with a lot of
experience so our commander cannot say
that he is
I don't know most so he's smarter than
us
they conduct their mission under the
trees using the internet to live stream
information to their Commander if they
spot enemy activity their Superior calls
in a strike
this is Modern Warfare the drones are
cheap they're compact these guys don't
need much equipment but they can be
deadly and the ukrainians know how to
use them
in this footage the team spot three
Russian soldiers in the center of the
screen
here strikes are called in the unit
monitoring their effectiveness from
above
during our visit the battlefield was
relatively quiet we just saw that the
general picture that okay no infantry is
coming so okay that's what you were
checking for Russian for Russian troops
their off-the-shelf Tech now works with
traditional kit like these 50 ton
howitzers Made in Poland
it's called a crab and the Ukrainian
Commander says he's lucky to have one
all the information in here it's all
written in Polish
questions
like their colleagues with drones this
unit lives under the trees they emerge
when they're provided with new
coordinates
and we saw it fire twice
using shells designed to kill enemy
troops
the DIY drone units help to improve
their accuracy and that helps the tank
commanders to conserve their shells but
the Russians also use drones are you
safe in the trees
the ukrainians are finding new ways to
fight a mighty aggressor and their
Ingenuity will be analyzed for years to
come
John Sparks Sky News near bucknut
eastern Ukraine